TIME AND THEY ARE RED HOT AT Mc
TERRIFIC YEAR, JORDAN EBERLE,
MISSING JADEN SCHWARTZ FOR SURE
O'REILLY FORN EXTENDED PERIOD
OF TIME.
WELL, 35 SECONDS MORE.
NOT MUCH.
>> John: NOW A PASS UP THE FARI
THIS YEAR A SON OF
FORMER BRUIN TED DONATO.
NOW A
SAVE BY DRIEDGER ON KYROU WORKI
LAUZON, THE FOR
THE KRAKEN.
HE WAITS.
NOW SEATTLE AS THE
BLUES B THE FORMER
WINNIPEG JET,AGAIN.
FORMER FIRST ROUNDER BY
EDMONTON. FRONT WIDE OPEN, AND
SAVE OVER 50%.
>> Darren: BOY, THEY'VE DONE A
NICE
>> Darren:IT.
HERE'S O'REILL
BUCHNEVICH, AND NO ICING AS THEY
BENCH IS MIKKOLA, WAITS, SHOOTS
IT
AND BORTUZZO NOW FOR IS WIDE OP.
IT'S A LITTLE KEEP
PLAYED AROUND BY THE K
>> Darren: NOW THOMAS, SHOOTS
AND GO AND A SAVE AGAIN BY
DRIEDGER ON ROBERT THOMAS..
AND A LONG DRIEDGER,
COMES AROUND TO THOMAS, TO THE
ATTACK PASS RIGHT THERE AND THE
BLUES ARE OFF ANDED THERE BY
BORTUZZO.
AND HAD HIS SECOND IN
THE HALF BOARDS AT FIRST, HE
READS THE PLAY THERE WITH A GOOD
STICK BUT BARBASHEV BACK WAIT U.
>> John: AND IT'S
AUSTON MATTHEWS AND THE LEAFS.
>> Darren: THEY'RE GOING TO BE
GOURDE HERE TRYING TO LEAN FOR
THAT WITH ABOUT
HE'S HAD AN EXPLOSIVE NIGHT, MA.
6 ON 4 ADVANTAGE HERE.
A DEJECT
KRAKEN TEAM WHO